foreign
America has failed Millennials so badly
that they're turning to a thousand
dollar per month side hustles to make
ends meets please so the side hustle has
become a big part of people's lives two
and five adults in the US have a side
hustle according to a recent Bankrate
survey of 2500 people and 53 percent of
them are Jen's ears and half are
millennials and then 40
are gen xers and 24 are baby boomers so
the argument here which you can read
some of these data points is that
millennials
have been born into a time where It's
just tough right so as you leave College
It's the Great Recession and your the
job market was all whacked out when we
all entered the the workforce and then
we were the generation that that loaded
that student loans you know to to the
degrees that we know now we were kind of
the first big generation to take those
on now the housing market it's like it's
it's impossible to buy a house now so
that's what this article is is is kind
of uh oh yeah come on Old kin here we go
this is my old man friend this is this
is gonna give his old man oh cranky can
take now the headlines that's true
though everything I did say is true in
defense of Millennials it is but let me
let me let me just wait a second I think
you're gonna agree with me on this one
even though you're not old and cranky
the headline says America has failed
Millennials so badly that they're
turning to a thousand dollar per month
side hustles the article goes on to say
Millennials in particular
have been struggling to keep their heads
above water for years
after hopping around a rocky post Great
Recession job market dealing with
inordinate student debt I agree with
that more on that in a moment and
shopping around a difficult housing
market all of which has made it harder
for them to become financially
independent now let's dive into this
this sounds like a sob story but here's
the reality okay America has failed
generations of students
by pushing
student loans
we have an entire documentary on it
and and borrowed future lays out the
horror stories so I will say that the
that the government the federal
government along with the student loan
programs and politicians who want to see
a lot of universities popping up all
over their state because that lends to
more taxes bigger job bases which means
they get reelected now that's all I'm
going to say about that but that's
what's going on and we have failed
people because we've put them into this
notion that getting a college degree is
the best way to success and that
narrative is changing so for that I
agree but here's the problem Millennials
and gen Z are struggling
paycheck to paycheck because they think
they're supposed to live the lifestyle
that their parents live and they don't
realize I got to build up to that and
credit cards are easier than ever to get
credit card debt at an all-time high we
hear that headline every month so you've
got young people who are absolutely
strapped with student loan debt and
credit card debt you take those two and
only those two factors yeah and here's
where we go they need an extra job and
we act like this is a crisis it's a
crisis as it relates to them having to
work a second job it's a crisis of debt
and if you remove the student loan
payment you remove the credit card
payment then these kids aren't having to
work an extra job so
this this is what's here's what's
concerning me this headline and that
excuse making by this writer is what
creates
the expectation problem that is driving
all of this I deserve this I deserve
that I want this I want that well listen
number one you don't deserve it and I
don't give a crap if you do want it if
you can't afford it then don't do it and
yet we've created this soft expectation
driven society and then we go we need to
do something about it what there's no
solution in this article at all it just
keeps talking about how many people have
to work an extra job well let me tell
you something on the Ramsey show we put
people on that stage across there that
do that extra jobs all the time and they
get debt free and none of them are
griping about it so there's the old
cranky Ken no I appreciate it okay well
and I don't have any data to back this
up so this is where you go into
dangerous territory but I I I am always
fascinated by generationally what you
experience right so the Boomers were
raised by people that had seen the
depression even right or or had World
War II close relatives from depression
to war to the great the great generation
right so that's what the Boomers saw
they take this whole idea of the 1950s
the man leaves and goes and works nine
to five wife stays home this whole
picture that's created you know and then
they they have kids that are now me
right so I was raised by Boomers I just
love that word I just love it so much
it's not said as a term of admiration
okay Boomer that's what the kids like no
I know I know you know and so like so
what we saw was something and then it
was like I think our generation was one
of the first because the internet really
started playing a part of your life like
you know later in in college when when
Facebook came about like like all this
stuff started happening this
connectivity to the world unlike any
other generation so we really became one
of the most social conscious generations
with giving uh the ability to go do
things
um that looked different than just the
standard lifestyle that was that we all
most of us saw in our parents and so it
does create this new world and then you
lay on top of all of this right you
graduate into the the housing bubble had
busted banks are closing I mean like
crazy right the Great Recession was nuts
right and you're entering that and at
the same time it's like you you have
like you said a level of expectation
that again for the first time social
media I think this level it's not just
Billboards and magazines that you're
seeing you're seeing real life people
living a certain way so subconsciously I
feel like there's some level of human
mind that just says oh yeah if they're
doing that or this or that
yeah then I should be to them their age
and you know what I mean like oh well
you're absolutely comparison yeah all
that starts playing in uh and then you
add on student loans you know then you
can go down the list but I think the
hardest thing and what's so difficult on
this show that we try to communicate so
often when people call in with money
issues is that like math
it doesn't have emotions
your money doesn't have feelings it is
what it is and so there's a level of
reality that has to sink in to say I
just can't do that and even though I'm
frustrated about the housing market I'm
frustrated that if I had bought a home
in 2018 it would be double the size and
if I'm buying it now like all of those
all of that is so real like that that is
a very real
um emotion and feeling to have but the
problem is is when that starts to drive
your decisions yes and there's a level
right that you have to be able to say
here's my here's my situation what what
now am I going to do about it yeah great
segue so of the response so what we gave
you were the data of of how many in each
generation are having a side hustle now
here's why
33 percent of the respondents said they
need the extra job the side hustle to
afford regular living expenses so these
are people that are living above their
means 33 33 are going I need it just to
make ends meet or whatever pay that my
rent or credit card everything else like
oh okay I want this I want this
membership here and I got this car right
so this car payment I gotta have a car
it's 800 a month so I gotta go work at
Kroger and that's not fair sorry that
voice just comes out sometimes 27 said
it helps with discretionary spending now
this would be responsible okay so now
they're going you know what we'd like to
send our kid to a summer camp or I'm
making this up and they go in order to
do some of these extracurriculars
whether they be single or married or in
a family situation 27 are saying I work
so that we can have a vacation good for
you yeah so it's not all snowflakes here
that don't know how to handle their
money right then
um 12 are using it to repay debt these
would be Ramsey Show listeners and
viewers they're going I'm getting after
it I'm going to pay off debt so I did
want to at least share that it's not all
people that are just going I I don't
know how to handle my money but a big
part of it is yeah uh We As Americans we
don't have discipline with our money
because we want it now we've been told
you get to have it now you deserve to
have it now you should have a nice car
nice house and all these things in your
20s well and it's hard to go backwards
Ken and I think there's a reality too
once everything's paid like just your
general stuff
there's not a I mean there's not a ton
left always and so uh just the price of
life and and I think inflation kind of
plays in I think there's like levels of
all this stuff that things just have
cost more and to go backwards and say
okay we're actually gonna have to cut
things to keep the same lifestyle that
we had like that sucks that's not fun
but sometimes that's the decisions that
have to be made